how's it going everybody it's Warren and
if you solve the Batman first look at
Robert Pattinson 'he's the Batman suit
yesterday or just now in this video I
want to know what you think about it so
let me know in the comments down below
it was a very sudden reveal but an
awesome one nonetheless one that we have
been waiting for for a very long time
and with this reveal of Robert Pattinson
as the Batman and with the reveal of the
bat suit for the very first time came a
very dark Easter egg and it comes in the
form of the bat logo on the Batman's
chest if you take a close look at it you
may notice that it has a very peculiar
shape it's not just one piece of solid
metal forge to make the bat symbol
instead the bat symbol on his chest is
made from the gun that killed his
parents that Joe Chill used and it seems
like director Matt Reeves is going to be
taking from Detective Comics number 1000
titled manufacturer for use and Batman
year 2 the story of that man forging the
gun that was used to kill his parents
into his bat symbol is very quick but
it's a very awesome story in Detective
Comics number 1000 manufacturer for use
Batman retrieves the gun used by Gotham
City mugger Joe Chill who murdered his
parents Alfred expresses his disapproval
for the gun telling Bruce that adding
this gun to his trophy case is too grim
even for you but Bruce replies that he
actually has plans for it since he
fights with Gotham's bad guys so often
they try to stab him in the chest so he
melts the gun down reforge is it as a
metal plate that goes underneath the bat
symbol on his chest so that it can serve
as a protection rather than causing him
harm which is truly awesome because
obviously the gun that killed your
parents would probably haunt you for a
very long time and instead of letting it
haunt him he turns it into a protection
for him and the truly awesome comic
strip he says I'm going to burn the
metal that killed my parents and Forge
it into something useful so the metal
that broke my heart as a child that same
metal will protect my heart as a man and
that is justice so super props to Matt
Reeves from taking from this awesome
comic strip but it also seems like we
may get something from Batman year too
since it is reported that the film is
going to take place when Robert
Pattinson is Bruce Wayne is going to be
Batman for only his second year it kind
of makes sense that they would pull
from Batman year 2 where Bruce Wayne
takes the gun that was used to kill his
parents and he seals the gun away in the
walls of the Wayne foundation building
so this is something that we could see
play out in the movie Bruce Wayne hides
the gun in the walls of the Wayne
foundation building but in year two of
him being the Batman he strips it from
the walls forges it down into a chest
plate or as we can see in this reveal
the bat logo and if you look at it you
can clearly tell that the inside pieces
of the bat logo does look like a barrel
of a gun and then the rest is obviously
forged from the gun as well so so far
our first look was absolutely fantastic
and it seems like Matt Reeves is going
to do a great job at deriving from some
of the most epic comics of Batman so let
me know what you think about this Easter
Egg and let me know what you think about
the first reveal of Robert Pattinson in
the Batsuit be sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe and notifications turned
on to stay up to date on everything
relating to DC and Marvel and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 and picking a winner
at 550,000 subscribers as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll forth